today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i put the link right below
this video
welcome to the show i have some
interesting clips to play for you
some very important stories to discuss
and one of the biggest areas of concern
that's really
it's really turned into kind of a mask
off moment for much of the american
right and the trumpian right is the
degree to which
all sorts of people have been just
falling all over themselves to defend
kyle rittenhouse the shooter in kenosha
wisconsin and um you might remember that
last week tucker carlson sort of
defended the vigilantism
of kyle rittenhouse and more recently
tucker carlson
interviewed one of the attorneys for
kyle rittenhouse i'm going to tell you
about some of the other attorneys
momentarily it's quite a cast of
characters
but when interviewed this um
attorney essentially turned this
into praise for what an accurate
marksman and how controlled
the behavior of kyle rittenhouse was
that he didn't shoot
more people given the situation if you
follow what his attorney says here
given the situation a lesser i was going
to say a lesser man
a lesser kid would have maybe shot
even more people than kyle rittenhouse
did so check this out and by the way
we're going to get to this but
it turns out that rittenhouse's other
lawyer so i'm going to play video of
john pierce
kyle rittenhouse's other lawyer appears
to be a q anon
conspiracy theorist like every detail is
insane
but let's start with attorney john
pierce talking about what kyle
rittenhouse did
is just amazing you know kyle the only
individuals that that kyle
shot were the three individuals that
were attacking him
and putting him at risk of serious
bodily harm or death
this is a 17 year old kid this is this
is amazing
so let me ask you this and i think
that's a that's a fair point he didn't
shoot indiscriminately and in in
i'm taking your word for in the first
one because i i haven't seen the video
but in the second two i have seen the
video
one guy attacked and the other guy it's
some it's it's amazing
what he did what what does that even
mean
amazing is not the word that i think of
like it's amazing he didn't
shoot more people is that the argument
is that an argument that you could
make with a straight face in a court of
law
uh and i want to reverse reverse the
framing just
just for a second here um
you are going to see them actually
portray
part of they've shown some of their
cards they are going to try to portray
kyle rittenhouse
as a law abiding militia dude who was
merely keeping the peace
they're going to try to make this 17
year old who is too young to even be
carrying a gun in this way in wisconsin
legally
they're going to try to make him into
the good samaritan
because he was out there helping he was
helping
out there and of course this actually to
some degree reminds me
of the george zimmerman scenario with
trayvon martin
where when a vigilante claims
self-defense
it's like a bank robber robber saying
the teller got aggressive during the
bank
robbery or like george zimmerman
saying i had to defend myself in a
confrontation with trayvon martin
which i created by being a
cop wannabe in my neighborhood watch
group or whatever it was
it was that he was doing years ago so
that's attorney john pierce saying
it's amazing this guy's a hero rather
than a criminal
then we have the other lawyer one of the
other lawyers for kyle rittenhouse
who's completely out of his mind i'm
talking about lynne
wood lynn wood is part of a
uh an organization called the fight back
foundation
which is about using lawsuits
to stop the lies and smears of the
radical left
and lynnwood said on twitter that the
fightback foundation is going to be
funding kyle rittenhouse's defense team
they've got donors holding this kid up
as a hero in funding his defense team
and lynnwood's twitter profile has the
hashtag
wwg1wga
you might be wondering what the hell is
that it's a q anon
thing and it stands for where we go one
we
go all it's a line from the 1996 jeff
bridges
uh sailing adventure white squall
which they miss a tribute to president
kennedy it's crazy but it's a q anon
uh hashtag and i mean you know
step back for a moment what better way
to make these killings into political
events
than to have a political organization
represent the killer that's effectively
what these lawyers are
pierce the attorney i played a clip of
earlier
was put on leave from his law firm then
called pierce bainbridge
beck price and hect after a report found
that he was accepting money from a
lender for personal use
and supposedly it was four million
dollars
a month before he was put on leave there
was a lawsuit from a former partner
accusing employees of the company of
financial and sexual misconduct as well
as sexual assault
i mean it's like there's just no depth
to the depravity of everybody involved
in this situation
and he's being represented kyle
rittenhouse is
by a group who are as shady as you would
expect
in a situation like this where they seem
to be seeing this more as an opportunity
for self-promotion than to good than an
opportunity to do
good legal work um i now
i guess i should mention there's a good
chance they're going to be able to muddy
this up
in the process of defending kyle
rittenhouse his lawyer
lynn wood is saying you know he didn't
actually transport the gun across state
lines he got it from a friend
as if that's a defense of course that
means the friend committed a felony by
giving a gun to someone under 18.
he then aided and abetted by by loaning
that gun
kyle rittenhouse of course was illegally
in possession of that firearm in the
state of wisconsin it's illegal for
anyone under 18 to have a weapon in
wisconsin even though it's an open carry
state
kid should have known that but he didn't
and uh pay
attention to that and killed two people
so there's a lot of really
ugly stuff here that's not even being
mentioned but they are
trying to and partially succeeding at
turning this kid into a hero and people
are donating to his legal defense fund
the lawyers are out of their minds and
this could be
i mean listen the justice system needs
to work its way
uh work its process but there's already
some really ugly red flags going on here
hey this is kind of interesting and i
think it's a good opportunity for an
important
discussion msnbc host joyanne reed
a joyride i guess she goes by now on
tuesday
she was accused of islamophobia over
some remarks that she made
on the monday evening program where she
kind of equated radicalized trump
supporters
to quote the way muslims act and of
course
that doesn't sound good and she is
rightly being criticized and i think
this was actually a missed opportunity
to bring something to the forefront that
is a really important discussion to have
so the setup is that they were having a
panel on her program
about president trump not denouncing
his supporters role in the via uh in in
being violent at protests in kenosha
and in portland and after noting
how trump liked a tweet praising
vigilante kyle rittenhouse and cheering
pro
trump demonstrators in portland reed
tried to make a point about the
president radicalizing his base and it's
sounding like
the way muslims act it doesn't sound
good and it wasn't good take a look at
the video
when thing when leaders um let's say in
the muslim world
talk a lot of violent talk and
encourage their supporters to be willing
to commit violence including on their
own bodies
in order to win against whoever they
decide is the enemy
we in the u.s media describe that as
they are radicalizing
those people particularly when they're
radicalizing young people that's how we
talk about
the way muslims act when you see what
donald trump is doing
is that any different from what we
describe as radicalizing people
i i don't believe so so joy reid is
being rightly
criticized here because she's saying oh
so all muslims are radical she's using
language where she says
the most radical trumpists are like
muslims generally and of course that
couldn't be further from the truth
we've got over a million muslims the
overwhelming majority as we all know
are not radicals and they're not violent
and all of that stuff
but there was really an opportunity here
to have an important conversation
the conversation to be had and i would
have been
with only a slight change to wording joy
reid would have been able to do it
the conversation is extremism starts to
look the same
anytime religious fanaticism or
cult-like behavior is at play and
when you look at right-wing christians
and the most extreme
movements within right-wing christianity
when you look at radical
islamists when you look at trump
cultists with guns
they are all very similar the cult-like
reverence to
whatever sometimes it's god sometimes
it's a religious leader sometimes it's a
cult leader sometimes it's
in the case of trump an elected official
that is a real
consideration and in fact it's part of
the conversation where when we talk
about
political violence you often see it
categorized
as right-wing violence including stuff
like militias and sovereign citizens and
white nationalists
eco-terrorism like you know the the
small
slice of political violence that would
be based on things like
climate defense on the left very rare
and then islamic political violence i've
made the case for years
that if you believe religion should be
the supreme law of the land
and you are willing to go and commit
violence in the name of religion
it doesn't really matter what religion
that is that's almost certainly
right-wing violence so i've been saying
for a while
radical islamic violence is right-wing
and when you look at
the precepts and the beliefs of radical
islamists and compare them to radical
christians and white nationalists who
are often influenced by
christianity they're really almost the
same
different details internally and they're
really all
right wing so i get why joy reed is
being criticized
she didn't address this the right way
she simply said this is how muslims act
which sounds like she's saying this is
how all muslims act
and it's important to remember that when
we on the left talk about this
i never say all republicans ex
all trumpists why we don't say all
muslims x of course
and the missed opportunity here would be
to say
um what we are talking about here
is that radicalism all starts to look
the same
we should be able to apply the same
language to it when we talk about
trump radicals muslim radicals or
whoever
congresswoman ilhan omar tweeted about
this saying quote
honestly this kind of casual
islamophobia is hurtful and dangerous we
deserve better and an apology for the
painful moment for so many muslims
around our country should be forthcoming
it is hurtful and it's unproductive
but it should be okay to talk about how
all extremism starts to look very
similar
in a way that's serious and in a way
that's over sober so
joy reid missed an opportunity to say
these radical trumpists show the same
type of radicalization that we see in
all radicals
including radicalized muslims who these
radical trumpists claim to
oppose they are more similar in fact
than they would have you believe that
has to be okay to talk about
i believe that if joy reid had couched
it in those terms
it would not have gotten the backlash
that it received a radical is a radical
it doesn't matter if it's uh you know
based on race color creed politics
radical is radical and it all starts to
look the same
let me know what you think i'm on
twitter at d pacman remember to get the
daily
audio podcast on spotify stitcher
itunes wherever you listen to your
podcasts the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
8 bucks a month and you get the entire
library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
let me remind you that the david pakman
show is
mostly funded by people who sign up
at joinpackman.com everyone is welcome
regardless of age
regardless of national origin you can
sign up from anywhere in the world and
people regularly do
uh and it is the primary funding source
for our program so consider yourselves
invited you will get the
award-winning awards we give out but
still award-winning bonus show every
single day
as well as commercial free audio and
video streams of the show
at joinpakman.com let's see what's on
the minds of
some of our viewers and listeners we are
going to go to the phone lines at
617-830-4750
starting with our caller from the 214
area code caller from 214 what's your
name
and where are you calling from
hello dave hang on one second i'm trying
to get you back we're
okay you there i'm here
hey this is dave calling from dallas
texas and uh
thank you for taking my call yeah uh so
whenever
people get on unemployment they
typically don't get their full paycheck
i think they get something like 60 or 70
percent
so when i heard that first heard that
they were going to be giving an extra
600
to people on unemployment i assume they
were going to give people the difference
between you know their paycheck and you
know what they would have gotten an
unemployment up to a maximum of 600
dollars
right so i was pretty shocked when i
heard they were going to give everybody
an extra 600
and i think right now they're looking at
maybe even extending that
so i think a better use of that money
would be to of course give unemployed
people
their the equivalent of their full
paycheck but then
use the rest of that money to maybe help
small business owners
and the self-employed who in many cases
have seen their income drop dramatically
and in some cases had it taken away
completely because they were forced to
shut down entirely
so i'm just wondering if you think
that's the best use well
so remember dave that the it turns out
that there was money left over in the
ppp
fund as far as i most recently saw so
there was actually you know your your
idea of taking some money out of
unemployment and giving it to small
businesses
small businesses didn't even scoop up
the money that was available so it's
unclear to me that that's really the
solution now what it sounds like
your concern is and i understand the
concern it's should anybody be making
more on unemployment than by working
that seems to be the fundamental concern
you have right
no actually it's not my fundamental
concern is that with the ppp program
that's that's really helping the
employees as well
only 75 percent of a ppp loan has to be
used
to pay your employees that's correct the
business owners only get 25 percent
so the business owner the only help that
the government is often offering
business owners
is debt in the form of low interest sba
loans and maybe helping you with 25
on your rent for your utilities yeah i
mean a lot a lot of that is forgivable
remember so it's not
it's not alone in practice but i think
i'm now better understanding
what you're saying which is the ppp
would allow you to keep your employees
on and pay them but it doesn't generate
demand necessarily for what you're
selling and your business revenue may be
in the tank what if the some of the
money could be used for that instead
yeah but you know i guess what i'm
talking about too is things like you
know the guy who used to cut my hair
and i said used to cut my hair because
i'm not going to get my hair cut anymore
yeah
right he's his business has gone off
dramatically i know a lady who's
uh who has a event planning business
she has literally no business now right
you know she her business is gone
my wife for example owns a pet sitting
company pet sitters depend on people
traveling or having to go to a job every
day and needing her dog taken out in the
middle of the day
her business is down 70 percent right
you know so now david did you did you
know that
i know your your concern is sole
proprietors here i don't know if you
knew
but the unemployment benefits were
expanded
to include sole proprietors and people
who work for themselves
who normally would not qualify for
unemployment and i think that that's
important as well i don't know if you
knew that
yeah i did not know that yeah yeah yeah
so i actually called my representatives
and asked them what they were doing to
help people like my wife
yeah and i've been just told basically
about the ppp loan
and i point out to them well that's
really not for the the employer that's
really for the employee more
mostly right no i know i know like for
example um
i know social media consultants who just
work for themselves who have gone on
unemployment and they would not normally
be able to
uh but but they they were i mean listen
the details
are are in some cases not perfect
but overall the situation is a mess i
don't think that the government has done
nearly enough when you compare us to
other countries but it seems like you
know on the details we could certainly
talk about it all day
yeah well let me ask you one more thing
do you think that that
actually that this whole uh 600 extra
dollars
actually kind of feeds into the
conservative narrative that democrats or
socialists who want to pay people not to
work that's another thing about it i
will say
well it's the trump administration who
did it and it's trump who said that he
was very much in favor of it so
i guess is trump the socialist is what i
would say to them
i agree with you i'm just saying that
that's what that's what how
conservatives are going to spend it
they're not going to say trump's
association
well then i'd say i tell them if you
don't like it vote trump out because
trump's the guy who did it
i i agree with that that's actually a
that's a good comeback on that and
before i let you go can i just make one
other quick comment yeah something i've
been hearing you and a lot of other
people saying
sure i keep hearing people say that
biden has to win in the landslide
that this has to be a decisive victory
you know in my lifetime i don't think
i've ever heard of republicans say they
have to win in a landslide
in fact i don't think they think they
have to win they just think they have to
convince us
that they won by at least one vote right
i think it's great to say we have to win
the landslide
but maybe you guys should also throw in
the caveat at the end of the day
just like the republicans all we have to
do is win even if it's only by one vote
i agree with you we only have to win by
one vote
it would be better to prevent trump from
doing more of his shenanigans to win by
more than one vote but you're completely
right you only need to win by one
all right dave from dallas thank you for
the call i appreciate it
uh a lot of a lot of important issues
there let's go next to our caller from
the 508
area code 508 what's your name where are
you calling from
hello can you hear me yes i can who's
this
yes um i am adam from oster
and i just want to start off by saying
that i've been a big fan of your show
for
many for like 10 years now thank you
it's just for the past couple of years
i have been quite disappointed with your
russia investigation coverage really too
you don't seem to put you don't seem to
put out there to your viewers
counteracting evidence that discredits a
lot of this
um the russia gate narrative that's been
pushed by the democratic party i'm on
the left
yeah i i hate trump i just
i just think for the past couple of
years this is like a bit of conspiracy
theory that's not really based on a lot
of
facts okay so adam can we let's slow
down though because you're saying a lot
and we want to make this a conversation
what specific assertion have i made that
was incorrect
well um well
you your last russia video was about
uh that it's not a hoax that it's
that it's it's not it's because of some
information that came out about paul
manafort
the entire investigation was started
fraudulently no so adam let's let's
let's just deal with that
so the the the recent video
was an analysis of a report that was put
out
by the senate select committee headed up
by
a republican richard burr which
confirmed
most of the initial suspicions about
interactions between the trump campaign
and russia
in the time leading up to the election
now
for you to say okay go ahead yep
yes so with paul manafort it killed
kilimnik right
that's one of dozens of components yes
did you know what paul manafort was
doing in ukraine
he was doing a lot of different things
over a long period of time but i don't
know
if which ones which things you're
talking about and how they're relevant
to what's in the report
well it is relevant because there's a
narrative out there that
that paul manafort and in kilim nick
were
like were just were trying to put its
bidding
or the the funny the record but hold on
adam adam hold on a second
did i say that or what are you
responding to right now because i don't
say that in the clip you just mentioned
to me what i say in the clip
is read the senate select committee
report
and you will see that if your
expectation was
trump and putin are going to get caught
on video colluding
that obviously did not happen and it's
not what the outcome is going to be
but if you look at the regular
connections and interactions
between the trump campaign and russians
they are confirmed by the report now you
can disagree with the report but that's
not
me right i'm just telling you what's in
the report
you don't like but one what i'm what i'm
counteracting is your assertion that
it proves that it's not a hoax of course
it's not
so how would it be a hoax when you've
seen countless arrests
and essentially everything that was
seriously alleged with evidence
proven either in the mueller report or
in the senate select report
if you're trying to cartoonify the the
claim if you're trying to say listen
david
you were expecting trump and putin to
get caught in bed together colluding
and for trump to be removed then i would
say i never said that i don't know who
was saying that but maybe you should
talk to them but
you it sounds like you're saying it was
a hoax when every serious investigation
has turned out that it was not a hoax
now
if you're saying does it matter if
you're saying
does it is it relevant to trump's
reelection or whatever
i'm probably right there with you but to
say it was a hoax
seems completely without evidence well
i'm not
i'm not i'm not saying i'm not saying
that
the investigation itself is that it just
made
it just what i'm saying is that
the the with paul manafort and kim
kilimnik it doesn't so what if he had
connections with some russian people
killing nick
he was the state department department
intel source with
100 pages that that might that
mueller himself had that described
kilimnik as a sensitive intelligence
source
for the u.s state department
right but it was but it was trump's
campaign chairman
who was briefing him on the campaign it
was not those were not in
who so then that would be an argument
for american intelligence to be dealing
with him in some way
and if you want to claim that they
should have been then you know go ahead
and talk about
that but that has nothing to do with
paul manafort in the propriety of that
interaction
they were business partners it wasn't it
wasn't
of course they were gonna communicate
and uh there's als
my main problem with this this russia
narrative is that it's it's just not
based on reality people
people are using it to describe trump as
a puppet of russia
but adam hold on a second hold on a
second hold on a second
who is doing that because this is not
even an issue i mean
on my program this hasn't even been an
issue for for like a year and a half at
this point
and we're focused on whether we want to
vote for joe biden or donald trump and
the failed handling of coronavirus i
mean you seem so wrapped up in paul
manafort and stories from a year and a
half ago
who's talking about this now who's
making this the issue for the election
like
what do you try do you are you trying to
get me to say i was wrong about
everything
find specific claims i was wrong about
then but so far
you're listening things i haven't even
said
i'm not saying i'm not i'm not here to
own you i'm a fan of yours
i get it but you said you're
disappointed in my coverage and so far
you've only listed
things adam hold on you've listed things
that i've not said
as why you're disappointed with me no i
said i've disappointed that you haven't
pushed back on this a lot of these
because you have pushed back a lot of
stuff like ill on omar
anti-semitism and even
the women's march i agree with you on
those it's
just that in here you have a blind spot
because there's a lot of facts that just
don't add up
to what okay so that's what i'm saying
tell me tell me what i've tell me what
i've reported
all right adam i gotcha i appreciate the
phone call
okay all right he hung up i'm very good
i mean it's like what so
okay i i just don't know where to go
with that i really don't
um let's take a quick break if you're
holding don't hang up because we will be
right back on the phones momentarily
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpackman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
okay let's go back to the phones at
617-830-4750 starting with our caller
from the 202
area code who's calling today from 202.
hi can you hear me yes who's this hi
david
my name is eleanor and i'm calling from
the dc area a long time listener for
some caller
love it and thanks
i'm wondering if you have any advice for
where i should put my focus
uh the next few months leading up to the
election i have some friends who say
they
won't vote for biden uh for various
reasons
either because they're unsatisfied with
the fact that he is not
um adopting enough or adopts
adopting enough uh progressive policies
in his platform others say
uh because of uh the allegations against
him they feel
they can't vote for him hold
uh sorry uh tara reed allegations
oh you you have friends who are saying
now in
in september that they can't vote for
biden because of the tara reid
allegations
uh wow and so i
for all these reasons i don't want to
have to
debate that with them
but so i'm wondering if i should even
try and talk to them or if i should
uh because i am getting involved with um
organizing programs in other states
right uh
states like pennsylvania and michigan so
should i just put my energy there
well i was going to say eleanor these
friends of yours that they don't want to
vote for biden because of tara reid's
allegations
what where are they voting uh
so like i said i'm in the dc area mostly
there so
but i do have some friends from college
i went to a college in a swing state
and uh so listen we've got we've got
weeks left until this election i would
not waste any time
arguing with people who are voting in
washington dc number one washington dc
is going to go overwhelmingly to joe
biden
it's an exercise in futility and
frustration so right off the bat
save yourself the time chop that
completely out of out of what you're
working on now
virginia's interesting i think that
there may be maybe there's an
opportunity to get involved in virginia
but the truth is that right now with
phone banking
you can decide to help in any state you
want to help in if you want to if you
look at
the georgia numbers and you say wow
georgia's closer than it normally is
i'm going to help phone bank in georgia
to get out the vote because it will
force trump to have to spend resources
there
maybe you do that maybe you say well
wisconsin is a likely state to be the
difference maker
electorally i'm going to phone bank
there i wouldn't waste my time arguing
with dc voters who aren't going to vote
for biden i
just wouldn't i think it's a waste of
time
right and okay that makes sense yeah so
thank you so much i do
really appreciate your advice and uh
because that i have been getting
involved
in say pennsylvania and michigan so i'll
just keep doing that
beautiful all right have a great day
thanks eleanor appreciate the phone call
yeah i mean listen guys at this point i
don't know that i
when half the country doesn't vote i
don't know that i'd be arguing with
anyone
even in the key states don't argue with
people
just identify the people who don't like
trump and explain to them how important
it is to vote and how easy it can be to
vote i think that's a much better uh
investment of time let's go next to our
caller
from area code 774
who's calling today from 774 and where
are you calling from just as importantly
hey david uh this is max from uh
hopkinton math
max from hopkinton you know i've never
been to hopkinton but i do see the signs
on the turnpike
what what is hopping hopkinton like
uh it's nice it's a small little town
you know small sea mass town
uh it's the start of the boston marathon
is usually how most people know it by
right all right very good well what's on
your mind today
gotcha so i know you've been stressing
like a lot about how um
you know we should i guess you know get
by in an office more so to get trump out
and i've always been told like my whole
life how you know everyone's vote
matters but i've been told
by those same people how that vote might
not matter if you vote uh independent
and i understand that in the context of
this election you're you know your
answer is going to be different but i
was wondering what your opinion is on
that
no my my vote my my position is the same
every election
every vote matters no matter who you
vote for or if you don't vote the
question is
what is your political objective and
does your vote support that objective or
does it take away from it so
because we have a first-past-the-post
voting system
rather than single transferable vote or
other ranked choice voting systems etc
if you don't like trump and you vote
third party
you're helping trump in a practical
sense now
if you vote in a state that like
massachusetts which will go to biden
you can make the case that you're not
really helping trump by voting third
party and that's a respectable case to
make
and then on top of that what would be
different this time around is
given that donald trump is so likely to
claim it was rigged
i think it's important to try to run the
score up in blue states
and in red states whether biden has a
shot or not
let's try to build the largest number of
of just raw
vote totals we can for joe biden so it's
not
i i disagree with the idea that it's
different this election i think your
vote
always matters and not voting matters it
has an
effect and we need to understand what
that effect is
totally awesome i think that was a great
answer really appreciate it and uh good
luck on the one mill
all right thank you yes very much
appreciate that things looking very
solid from the standpoint of a million
subscribers
as of right now we're at about 980
000 subscribers so we may have very
powerful news on that for people sooner
than later
let's see who else is holding how about
the 509 area code i'd love to hear
from our caller in 509 what's your name
where are you calling from
[Music]
509 i can hear some background noise
there i don't know if you're aware i'm
talking to you
[Music]
hello hello
[Music]
hello yes that's you
me yes you
from 509 509 yeah
oh wow that caught me off guard yeah i
was just curious i just
listened to samuel's package update from
the website hustle [ __ ]
and he said i'm sorry hold on a second i
don't unders i'm sorry i don't
understand a word you're saying it
sounds like you're coming to me from
underneath a towel what
you listen to what now it's a
um stimulus website um update
and the website's called hucklebitch and
i was just curious because he said that
the feds are dumping a lot of the
stimulus money
into the stock market to raise the stock
markets up
right and that uh what's his name steven
i can't pronounce his last name
[Music]
this is a website called hustle [ __ ]
yeah and he does stimulus updates okay
and then and the argument is is that
it's bad that the government is pouring
money into the stock market or just that
that's what the government is
he said he's made that there's
allegations that uh
feds are dumping a whole lot of the
stimulus money to raise the stock prices
up and everything else into
junk bonds and he also said that
machuchin or whatever his name is has
dumped a lot of stimulus money into some
of his
wealthy counterparts machuchin is out of
control
he's he's a loose cannon you never know
what machuchin will do but i guess they
they've opened up their coffers and
stuff to keep the stock market prices up
and it's not going to the stimulus
packages that they need to i guess
they're dumping trillions into it the
small allegations i've just heard i just
wondered if you've heard anything about
it too
yes so certainly there are multiple ways
in which stimulus money is used to prop
up stock market prices that the that's
absolutely happening now the junk bond
specific arguments that you're talking
about i i'm less familiar with
but i don't know the website you're
referring to i don't know exactly what
the allegations that are being made are
but early if you go back to my tweets at
the very start of this entire stimulus
one of the things i was tweeting about
was how the stimulus is being used to
artificially prop up the stock market so
that that
passes the sniff test for me
yeah and then the other thing is with
pelosi doing what she's doing now
i was kind of really angry at her but
after listening to that stuff i don't
know if she's right and holding off and
you're talking what specifically are you
referring to that nancy pelosi did
well between the arguments and stuff
between them and the republicans and
stuff about the stimulus packages and
stuff i was kind of getting angry at her
for not you know
getting something forward and everything
else yeah and now i'm kind of going well
maybe she has a good idea on not doing
this because of what they're doing over
the republican side
right what state do you vote in i'm
curious
washington washington state spoke
washington all right very good
okay i really appreciate the call thank
you
yeah like i said if you could get more
information about that for me so i could
be more informed
i will i'm going to look into that thank
you all right thanks for your time
all right take care uh okay
let's go next to our caller from the 410
area code who's calling today from four
one zero
hey david my name's jim did you say tim
or
jim jim with a j jim with a j
all right what's going on jim yeah uh
thanks for taking the call man
uh i hope everything's staying healthy
and you're well thank you
oh i just i i'm just going to get your
read on
the q and on stuff and and
i'm curious to see what percentage you
think of the
right is sort of
uh that is on board with some of that
that stuff and it's
you know i've only just kind of started
to hear about the q and on stuff and
um it seems problematic i'm just i'm i'm
curious what your read is on how
how much you might see that on the right
side of the aisle so
i don't have any independent assessment
but earlier this week i interviewed alex
kaplan for media matters and alex said
that
we're probably talking about millions
but not tens of millions that's that's
the the current
assessment that alex had and i would i
would you know defer to him on that
um and that seems about right if you
look at sort of like tweet volume
and facebook groups and remember some of
these movements
seem larger when you're looking at the
internet
but they're really not that big and you
know we saw that um
we've seen that with a lot of different
movements i think this is what surprised
a lot of people during the democratic
primary how did joe biden get all these
millions of votes
well if you just look online the sort of
bernie aoc left
seems bigger than it actually is and
that's not a praise or criticism it's
just a reality
i think that that may make q anon seem
like a bigger thing than it is but it
certainly seems to be in the millions
but short of tens of millions
yeah yeah yeah uh and so you don't think
that necessarily it might
have um it might it might not have a
massive
impact on sort of you won't see that
sort of voter ship
or reflected as much as one might think
based on headlines and stuff
in the actual vote in in the popular
vote in total
no but remember that there's 20
candidates
that are q anon affiliated on the ballot
in november
two of whom seem to have a real shot at
winning again according to what alex
kaplan told us earlier this week i think
if you get two cue and honors in the
house of representatives that's going to
start to take on
a little bit of a different picture
right
yeah and so you would think then that
most of the conservative bases
is more moderate or do you think it's
all right something that's
that's maybe a larger part of the
constituency or
no here's the thing when you have
something like q and on
it it doesn't really help us to assess
where the republican party is in general
because the these are really at least
for now
this is a relatively small group these
are outliers these are sort of it's it's
like a
it's a slice of trumpists and trumpists
are a slice of the republican party so i
don't really think that
cue non-existing tells us much about
the broader dynamics of the republican
party but you're getting to something
that i think is really important which
is
whenever trump leaves whether it's in
january or january of 2025 whenever that
is
what happens to the trumpists that are
left over
and how does that manifest in the senate
and the house of representatives in
governor's mansions
state senate etc and that's more of an
open question but i wouldn't make any
assessments about the republican party
from q anon really
yeah yeah that makes a lot of sense and
i think um
you know just building on that
you would say the majority of
republicans maybe are
are are uh more moderate or more
reasonable than
sort of those fringe groups so that
maybe well listen
if the if the standard for the
republican party has become
very radical over the last 20 years if
we're comparing to q anon
then okay i don't i don't think the
majority of the republican party does
not have
the beliefs of q anon but they have
their own radical beliefs in their own
way sometimes they're radical religious
beliefs sometimes they're radical
authoritarian beliefs sometimes they're
just
really widely debunked economic ideas so
it's not like a bailout for republicans
that they're not all as crazy as q anon
if you know what i mean
right yeah totally yeah yeah that's
great
and i think uh the comparison to the aoc
bernie stuff seems relevant to me but
but do you do you feel that there's a
similar sort of
striation of the party on our side of
the aisle as well or
i think the dynamics are very very
different because
some of these extreme movements some of
these extreme movements exist on the
left where they're so extreme that
they're not even really on the spectrum
of sort of like the normal political
spectrum where q anon is wacky it's like
this
these pizza gators and that type of
thing for the most part like the bernie
aoc wing of the democratic party
they're mostly voting for joe biden they
understand biden's closer to them than
trump and it makes sense to remove trump
that's like a normal way to interact
with the political system here in
massachusetts we had these primaries
everybody i know who supported joe
kennedy or alex morse
is now tweeting and posting that like
okay our person lost but we're obviously
voting for marky and richard neal
because they're better than the
alternatives
most people are operating in that way a
lot of the q anon people
are in a totally different universe
where they're not even on the political
spectrum in a normal way
right so so how then
how would you compare can you
give me more sort of i guess clarity on
how you would compare
the asc bernie sanders type of
spectrum you're talking about to the
queue and i'm like
do you think aoc and bernie are
are closer to to the center than like
the q arms or do you think
uh i just think it's the wrong analysis
i don't know that you can you know
conspiracy theorists
it's very tough to put them on the
political spectrum i mean look at
anti-vaxx as an example you have people
that end up as anti-vaxx on the right
because they're skeptical of government
and you have people that end up
anti-vaxx on the left because they're
skeptical of businesses
and they share their anti-vac sentiment
but if you say
where are they on the political spectrum
they're both they're all over it
and some are not on it at all like
they're not political other than they
are anti-vaxx
so i just don't think we can really
analyze it in such a sensible rational
way
yeah gotcha yeah yeah yeah that makes a
lot of sense
um cool i i can't think anything else to
ask you but um
all right i appreciate the phone call
yeah of course thank you thank you for
calling
david thank you uh great to hear from
you we are going to go
to a break and we will take calls again
very very soon the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners
and one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about them
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
okay let's get into audience questions
for the week starting with
what do you think would be trump's most
likely
october surprises to try to win the
election
so before we get into this there's a con
there's a the idea is common
that october surprises don't really work
i'm not so sure about that if you look
at james comey's decision to do a second
hillary clinton press briefing uh at the
very tail end of the 2016 election i
mean there were so many factors that
affected that election but it's hard to
say that that had no
impact when you look at george w bush's
bin laden
speech and announcements right before
the 2004 election in which he was
narrowly reelected arguably with a small
victory in the state of ohio
although there were some allegations of
foul play there in ohio
i don't know that we can write off an
october surprise now that being said
when more people vote by mail early
it does diminish the possible impact of
an october surprise
changing the outcome of any state for
example or of the the
total election because there are fewer
people left to vote right the more
if 50 vote before october 15 and it's
not going to happen but imagine
then what happens between october 15 and
the election can only possibly
impact half of the electorate instead of
the entire thing
now all of that being put aside um
i still think that an announcement about
a vaccine
from donald trump sometime in october is
going to be
the the move so to speak and i've
already said
if indeed a vaccine is approved in
october and
let's not you know there are people who
write to me and they say if
if there is a vaccine approved in
october i would be worried it's not
really safe
that's not really my concern i don't
think trump is going to announce a
vaccine that's not actually been
approved
i think trump's going to try to take
credit for that vaccine announcement
when it will have nothing whatever
to do with him it could be a vaccine
developed
in the uk for example the oxford vaccine
which is being discussed
it could be a vaccine that has been
around or in development for some time
for poultry coronavirus which has now
been modified which could be the one
i that doesn't seem like it but the
point is none of it would have anything
to do with donald trump
and yet he will announce it as if it is
his accomplishment
and i fear i used the term monday some
people liked it
i fear that because of the portion of
the audience that's
intellectually compromised i fear it
could actually swing
a little bit of the vote so that's my
top if you say
what would you bet on if you had to bet
on what the october surprise would be
it would be trump trying to take credit
for a vaccine or
some kind of really effective treatment
for example if one is found
beyond that you know there's the the old
faithful ideas
of some kind of conflict this is kind of
chaos pr
usually it's a foreign conflict that's
used
to justify reelecting the president we
have not changing horses midstream
with trump he seems to think that it's
generating chaos
within american cities that is going to
be good for him
and whether he would scale that up in
october we don't know whether it
actually helps him is not really clear i
think it's certainly possible that it
activates
some of his key constituents but we are
going to have to wait on that
now again it could i mentioned
earlier that there's going to be more of
mainland voting
absentee ballots than there typically
are and that could reduce the power of a
possible
october surprise the other side of it is
that
messing with the voting itself could be
the october surprise it wouldn't
necessarily be done in public although
hopefully we would figure it out
the trouble with trump lying all the
time
is that no one believes you eventually
and thus there could be the possibility
that trump comes up with some new
obama gate or trump makes a claim about
a virus treatment or whatever
and nobody will care because nobody will
believe it or at least not enough people
will miracle cure you know who knows
what it could be
the real surprise would be
him figuring out a way to secretly mess
with the election that we don't detect
and the surprise is everybody thinks
there's no surprise when
in reality he's finding new and novel
ways to mess with the election
that's what i'm most scared of followed
by just taking credit for a vaccine
and some people actually giving him
credit for it david you've mentioned
before the idea of police
having to live in the communities where
they are policing
do you think this should be made a
requirement so there's a couple
complications with that
when i gave my list of here's how police
should be reformed
one of the things i mentioned was
requiring
some portion of the police department to
live
where they are policing now if you think
of a really big city like new york city
you could be policing the bronx but
living in staten island and if you
understand
the sort of class and racial dynamics of
that
you might not think that that's
fantastic but
putting aside some specific examples i
think that the idea of requiring a
percentage of police
to live in the city where they are
working is a good idea the problems
include number one a lot of police
don't live where they police because
they can't afford it
and so if your paradigm is defunding
police
unfortunately defunding police is often
inconsistent
with requiring police to live where they
are policing and in fact
if you really want to do that you may
have to look at
maybe not salary increases but cost of
living
bonuses for police that are living
in some of the areas they police there's
a reason why lots of
nypd live 90 minutes out
in new jersey or in upstate new york or
you know not upstate but north of the
city
or wherever and it's because they can't
afford to live in new york city so
that's something that has to be
considered the other thing that i think
is
important is that the reason we want
police uh living in or
it's really the opposite it's more that
we want police
that already live where they are going
to be working
there's a number of reasons for that you
could be more likely to de-escalate
rather than escalate if you're policing
your own
community it would make you more
acquainted
with the dynamics of your city
in terms of better identifying what is a
threat and what isn't a threat and this
is not to excuse when police obviously
misbehave and
say something's a threat that obviously
is not after the fact in order to get
out of trouble
but understanding the dynamics of your
city
better would certainly be a really good
thing
and being integrated into the community
would be a really really good thing
the possible downsides would be are
police more at risk of retaliation
against themselves and their families if
they're known to live in the community
um is it um it
would that be something that we need to
think about could it lead to selective
enforcement because if you live in a
community and you police it
you develop relationships it could skew
your relationship where you
are no longer dealing with the community
objectively depending on whether you
know the people or whether you don't
i think that those are relatively small
risks i think that the
idea of saying all police must live
where they are policing
is impossible but i do think that the
idea of requiring a certain percentage
and if you need to give them cost of
living in order to be able to afford it
i would actually be okay with that
because i do think it would dramatically
improve policing
now let's step back from this question
there's a different question
that we also need to talk about which is
regardless of whether police come from
in the community or out of the community
there is a self-selection bias for who
wants to be a police officer
and there's lots of liberal police
officers i'm not
saying that there aren't but on average
police are more culturally conservative
than the average population and that's
something that we need to think about as
well
so you maybe would be able to deal with
that for example
if you have a liberal city that is
overwhelmingly
policed by rural police officers
who live in conservative areas an hour
and a half outside of a city
okay you could fix some of that
political imbalance
by bringing in people who live in the
city but that's a bigger question that
police departments are going to have to
deal with the cultural conservatism of
police there's a self-selection bias
it exists in the military as well
doesn't mean there aren't left-wing
people in the military in fact joe biden
is now
leading among members of the military
but that has to be thought of as well
when we think about
where should those who police us live we
also have to think about these cultural
components
hey david do you think joe biden should
bail on debating donald trump house
speaker nancy pelosi said that joe biden
shouldn't debate
because he's just going to lie she said
quote i don't think there should be any
debates i do not think the president
has comported himself in a way that has
any association with truth evidence data
and facts
she wouldn't legitimize a conversation
with trump
so i actually agree with nancy pelosi on
the facts
trump just lies he lies all the time he
insults people a debate with him
is a debasement of the discourse but
where i disagree with her is that it
wouldn't matter
because he is the president of the
united states and there's already people
who are trying to make the case that joe
biden isn't up to debate
that joe biden is suffering from
cognitive decline or dementia
and if joe biden were the one to say i'm
not going to debate because trump's a
liar
doesn't matter what reason joe biden
gives it would not be good for joe biden
now
the debate uh uh the the institution of
debate
in this election could not be less
important i said before the conventions
i don't need conventions and i don't
need debates because it's also clear
at this point in time but i do think
that there is a
real risk to joe biden if he bails it
would look
bad uh and also i think it actually
would be good for biden to debate
trump is not a good one-on-one debater
he'll insult biden
he will yell a lot he'll tell a lot of
lies but i don't think it's going to
endear him
to any undecided voters his supporters
will love it but i don't think it will
help
trump and biden is he's a decent debater
yes he's slowed down to some degree from
2012 when he debated paul ryan but
remember what happened with the bernie
one-on-one debate there were
expectations that biden would implode
he'd be unable to put together a
sentence or say anything coherent
biden did fine and he actually went on
to build a pretty significant lead
in democratic primary voting so i think
that biden is actually
fine to debate and again
you don't want to give any opportunity
for trump and don jr and everybody who's
been pushing it to
further these claims that biden is weak
in any way mentally weak
weak in terms of personality that he's
hiding in his basement or whatever the
case
lastly donald trump was able to do
certain things with hillary clinton
during the debates that he wouldn't be
able to do with joe biden
donald trump is gigantic physically as
you know
he's a very large man obese by any
sensible estimate of his height and
weight
and he was an imposing presence
lumbering behind hillary clinton
although she was not intimidated by him
certainly the images
i don't think um were ones that
would be possible with joe biden and i
think that
not that that was bad for hillary i
think
it would be bad for trump to try to pull
his standing really close to biden
antics
in the way that he did with hillary
clinton so as of right now the schedule
is
three presidential debates september 29
october 15 october 22 and then the vp
debate which i very much look forward to
will be on october 7th
the last two presidential debates
october 15th and october 22nd
those are pretty late particularly when
we're expecting more people than ever
to vote early by mail absentee or early
voting in person
it is going to be more about turnout
than convincing people to switch by
october 22nd if you've not
listened i've said before if you haven't
made your decision already i don't know
what's wrong with you i want to talk to
somebody who's actually undecided
if you've not made your decision by
october 22nd
it's a very weird situation but as a
result i think that those last two
debates are going to be more about
can trump dog whistle enough to activate
parts of his base
and the answer may be yes we're going to
be watching them all very closely we'll
be live streaming
all four of the debates we've got a
great bonus show for you today get
instant access
by becoming a member at joinpakman.com
or a patron at patreon.com
david pakman show
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor is blinkist the app that
lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
for free
and save 25 percent off of a
subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video